[Music]
[Applause]
joining us now the uh sports writer of
the year
jeff passin from the mothership covering
baseball how about a round of applause
jeff passing
look at that
congratulations there jeff now
as your reward you get to cover what's
going on in major league baseball right
now congratulations
um yeah before i get to the baseball
issues here derek jeter and the marlins
are parting ways
um why is that
um
what's the what's the best way to put
this uh philosophical differences are
probably the best way to put it at this
point and the degree of those
philosophical differences isn't
exactly clear at this point but
what's obvious is that bruce sherman who
derek jeter brought in as the money man
really when they purchased the marlins
from jeffrey lauria uh
boy almost five years ago now um and and
jeter's vision for where the franchise
is going
was not aligning and
uh derek jeter is derek jeter if he
wants to go do something he can say uh
peace out i'm gonna go do what i want to
do i've made enough money i have
a great situation and literally anyone
in the world will hire me so uh i don't
know what this means for derek jeter's
future in baseball in sports maybe he
goes somewhere else but uh is not with
the marlins anymore and i think baseball
as a whole is worse off for not having
him in it who's had a better
playing post playing career
a-rod or derek jeter
oh boy
is a rod still under contract with espn
because that might actually change my
answer now uh derek jeter's problem
wait you're saying jeter's had a better
post career a-rod's
on sunday night baseball fox post season
shark tank
uh owns a minnesota timberwolves
uh yeah you know what he's got the the
timberwolves part i had forgotten about
i i was just gonna say ownership always
beats participation so i was gonna go
with the ownership part of it but since
around actually still uh
and we don't know what percentage by the
way he owns um
i'm still going with jeter sorry all
right
all right so uh give us the cliff notes
version
um
don't lawyer this up here just give us
what what what do we need to know about
baseball right now what's the biggest
issue that is keeping us from baseball
right now
the biggest issue keeping us from
baseball is that major league baseball
teams and owners feel like they pay
players too much uh and that players
after years of mistreatment whether it
is salaries being lowered over the last
four years whether it's getting their
service time manipulated whether it's
free agency changing indignity after
indignity are pissed off and saying
we're tired of this and not going to
accept your garbage offer
that's essentially what it boils down to
and right now major league baseball even
though it has gone in the players
directions on a number of topics being
open to a draft lottery saying we'll
give you extra service time if you win
rookie of the year and a few other
things the money just ain't there yet
and and the thing that's holding this up
then is the luxury tax which is not a
surprise because it essentially has
functioned in many ways as a salary cap
over the last five years and all major
league baseball teams have wanted going
back to the dawn of time in the labor
organization in the sport has been a
salary cap
what happens today
um major league baseball cancels the
first week of games
and
suddenly some pressure is put on the
players to say okay are we really
willing to to give up paychecks here
because up until this point you know
they don't get paid during spring
training they don't get paid during the
off season
at this point it's starting to get
serious and the resolve of players is
going to be tested let me tell you
uh
this is the most resolute i've seen
players in my 20 years of covering
baseball i understand that it doesn't go
back to the 94 strike in the aftermath
but i think the complacency that labor
piece brought on among the players has
vanished at this point they are standing
behind max scherzer and standing behind
garrett cole and standing behind a
number of players big names who have
taken the leadership mantle and the
players association and are willing to
fight because they feel like if they
don't fight now they're never going to
win
i i saw this with the associated press
where they point out that max scherzer
is making
whatever per day garrett cole max sures
are driving a porsche to the meeting as
if to say you guys have enough money
nobody's telling me what the owners lose
each day and nobody's telling me what
they drove to the meetings or flew in
for these meetings i was just going to
say you know what they drove to the
meetings a private jet yeah that's what
they drove to the meeting yeah um i you
know i i think and and i have a column
going up later today and i i hope you
read it because i think you'll enjoy it
um
finance in baseball is a zero-sum game
dan
money goes either to the players
or to the league and owners and the
owners distribute it how they want to
they pay for certain things whether it's
payroll whether it's capital
improvements on their stadiums whether
it's staff front office whatever it may
be
but every dollar that doesn't go to
players goes to the man
and so if you want to be on the side
who's saying players get paid too much
then you are fundamentally on the side
that says
businessman
should get it and and you you know you
talk about dan how businessmen bear the
burden and run the risk and have all
that
major league baseball is a legalized
monopoly
that has revenues that are streaming in
every year if you are in a big market
you have a massive television contract
if you are in a small market you get all
sorts of national television revenues
and revenue sharing from larger markets
if you are losing money in baseball then
that's your fault because it's not hard
to be a successful businessman in
baseball the very thing you can look at
to illustrate that is the fact that
franchises right now according to forbes
are worth 55 billion dollars combined
when a decade ago they were worth 15.
what's the worst case scenario
the worst case scenario is there's no
baseball in 2022. i think there's a
small chance of that but i'll be honest
four months ago i thought there was a
small chance that we were going to get
to this point where games were being
lost and granted i'm still not there
that gay you know major league baseball
could say we're going to cancel games
there's still a month before they're
supposed to start man like there's still
31 days before opening day so the idea
that you're willing to have a four week
spring training but not willing to have
a three and a half week spring training
i'm sorry if they get something done in
the next week i think there's hope for
opening day starting march 31st if not
though like if this goes for a while i
think there are a couple of days that
are important um you have to remember
clubs make the least amount of money
during the six months of the season in
april
so
you know an operating thought in some
players minds has been well are clubs
willing to actually punt on april but as
my friend andy mccullough said uh in a
column at the athletic uh if owners are
willing to lose games in april then why
should you tune in in may
great stuff as always jeff and
congratulations on being a sports writer
of the year
thanks dan i appreciate it thank you for
having me where's the award
i believe it's in winston-salem north
carolina where i'm going to go down and
get it this summer and uh and and the
the sportscaster of the year more
important uh is the great scott van pelt
so uh being alongside him pretty damn
cool
thank you jeff
take care buddy that's jeff pass an espn
senior baseball insider